Hello hi welcome it's not a phase it's not a phase can you hear me good I'm
using I have to reset up everything on OBS so I don't know if it's good I didn't
test anything before starting here yeah here you okay okay okay I missed you
too I miss you too hello welcome I'm happy to have you here today
emo sister are you listening to MCR I'm not listening to MCR actually don't
really like any MCR songs I'm kind of a fraud I admit it I'm a fraud I'm a fake
emo yep that was the shower it was rushed it was rushed cuz I wanted to
get here to be with you um right update um I posted on my NSFW Twitter and to
see if you guys are interested in me posting my in me posting my previous
content on my Emi patreon I think I think I won't post it on patreon I might
post it on fansly so that way it's easier to avoid if you don't want to see
um yeah cuz I keep getting I keep getting questions asking like oh when
will you reopen your other patreon so I can listen to your other stuff and it's
like not anytime soon I don't know so yeah um wait you have a patreon shut up
stop being stupid so yeah um fansly is not up yet it'll be up in like a month
maybe I don't know I'm not sure yet but yeah it might be available there but
um not anywhere else yeah does it involve webbing no no um I think that's
everything oh yeah one more note I know it's very very early in the game to make
a 2.0 model okay and it doesn't mean that I don't like this model I think this
model is really cute you know I think I'm really cute but as an artist I'm very
very picky I'm super super picky so I want to customize myself more yeah
sorry I'm drinking tea right now I think it's peach tea with mango peach and
mango I think I hate mangoes but it's the only tea I have right now so yeah
it's been 75 years since I heard your voice well we're back we are so back so
and plus it's cheaper because I'm an artist so I can I can fucking make a
2.0 whatever I want if I wanted to I could just make the whole thing myself
but I'm lazy as fuck so I'm not going to do that right let me show you let me
show you what I've got going on
right I'm gonna make myself a little bit more there so here is a totally legally
acquired drawing program that I totally legally acquired and here okay I
traced the model art now I'm not gonna do that for the actual model I'm just
doing it for the design itself when I draw the model itself it's not gonna be
traced from this one I look like a fucking goblin I like why do I look
like this yes it is paint tool sides paint tool side too um let me drink some
actual water so um we are not gonna be bald I needed to be bald because I'm
gonna change my hair so this is the naked model I'm going to keep the band-aids
I'm gonna keep the wound tattoo and then I have all these elements I want to add I
guess so I want to keep my band-aids I want to keep my freckles I want to keep
them I think I wrote tattoo wrong I don't know I want to have some sort of
choker maybe a collar wait hold on let me this thing this has been annoying me
for a long time I didn't mean to do that this has been annoying me for a long
time my blinking I open my blinking parameters have been too sensitive so I
keep blinking at you let me make them less sensitive how do I do this maybe
shit I don't know how
maybe make them zero point
is that more or less sensitive I don't know okay you know what I should probably
not mess with that right now I should probably not mess with that right now
okay anyways anyway let me continue talking um right and so here's stuff I
want to incorporate so right now I'm wearing your sweater but I'm I think I
want to have your shirt too I think I'll take that too and then also I want to
have some sort of twin tails still I want to keep that sort of beam I want to
have multiple ear piercings that's right not just one I'm not dating my cousin
shut up I'm dating you I'm not gonna add a leash to the collar no I want to have a
split tongue yep I want to split it in half because I think that's hot um maybe
a belly button piercing I'm not really sure because I feel like I feel like it
might be too much around the belly area if there's both a belly button piercing
and a womb tattoo but I don't know maybe glasses maybe leg warmers and I'm still
on the fence on if I want to keep my book like like this book here I'm still
on the fence on if I want to keep that there I'm not sure yeah
so that's that and then here is my ideas that I went on Pinterest and found so
um this is this is your shirt the book is special it is special that's why I
kind of feel like I should keep it you know yeah I'll still have I think I want
to keep the pins on my head too I think those are cute and then I like these
sort of socks here like the striped nests I like kind of the unevenness of
it like different different lengths I don't have some fishnets to some sort
of fishnets if you lose the book how will you resurrect us I know I know I know
I'm sorry you're right maybe I'll keep it and then I really like this hairstyle I
know it's AI art but listen you can't fucking go on Pinterest these days
anymore and not find AI art so yeah I like these really short braids like
really really short that kind of on the side are on the side of her head too I'm
not sure if that makes sense and also like I'll have the same side bangs I
won't have these middle bangs I want a heart tongue piercing I want a heart
tongue piercing oh my god I think it's so cute I like this whole outfit I found
it on I found this one on Twitter I like this piercing here I think I'm gonna
flip the I think I'm gonna flip the cross upside down but I kind of like it
and then I cuz I I wanted to still have the loom tattoo visible so I thought
this was kind of like a good base outfit to start off with especially with
the fishnets can't you have two tongue piercings I guess but I don't think that
would look good I like these earrings I don't know if I'll have these ones
hanging down I'm not sure I don't want it I don't want it to be too complicated
but I keep ripping but we'll see don't be disappointed when Ronnie I know she's
not God I know she's not God I'm I might keep the same shoes I'm thinking of
keeping the same style but like dying them black I'm not sure I like I want I
like the jeans skirt here but I don't like the color and I feel like it's a
little bit too short and tight I might make it a little more flared out and
longer and I like the two bows on the on the on the pockets I think that's
so this is what I've compiled but obviously if you don't like something we
can change it get some J's what's J's like are those shoes hmm I think something
that some of you may not have noticed either is these are your shoes too
at least I think they're your shoes let me make sure let me just make sure I'm
I'm pretty sure those are your shoes too
videos lore let me scroll through the lore here yeah look oh wait I can't show
you I'll just I'll take a screenshot and then I'll add it to the drawing
program look these are your shoes that I'm wearing I stole a lot of your clothes
and now I'm gonna steal your shirt too yeah it's not big feet they're just big
shoes okay they're not big feet yeah good morning good morning
I'm a little skeptical about how of how all of these are gonna look together on
your cute and funny body but you're very talented artists so I'm excited to see
don't worry I'll make them fit I'll make them look good right so let's start
with the hair now normally I wouldn't do art streams because well I just feel
like people aren't really interested in watching me draw it's not really a I
think I need to I'm gonna just look at myself for a reference on on what my
looks like it's not really um something that even I watch a lot because I don't
find it entertaining either also notice not to you know to you not notice
self don't take anything I draw here as like um as like a good indication of my
art skills okay don't take don't take this as like an indication of how good I
am the art because I'm truly really um I'm not as bad I'm not as bad as I may
look okay I'm during the stream thank you my craft cursor you don't see it in the
art program do you I'm always interested oh thank you
I ran out of tea
I'm eating my mic too all right all right all right um what are you using to draw
yes a lovely lovely viewer gifted me a freaking who we on is that how you
pronounce it no wait sorry why come why come why come we come we come why come
I don't know um there it's like a really popular um brand of drawing tablet and I
never had one before I was really scared of getting a wake-up tablet because I've
always had like such bad experience with every single tablet I've ever gone
literally every single tablet I've ever purchased already had a similar literally
every single tablet I've ever purchased has always come to me broken it's always
been delivered to me broken so I was really worried oops I probably shouldn't
that I was really worried that if I got my head is so flat where is the brain why
do I have no brain here I was really worried that if I were to order a wake
up tablet then um it would come to me delivered and then I would have spent all
that money just to you know be annoyed so yeah did I say it would come to me
delivered it would come to me broken it would be delivered to me broken and I
don't want that to happen one brain cell in me I have more than one brain cell
I'll prove it to you I'll prove it to you but for some reason the model artist
which um that drew you know this model kind of gave me a really flat head like
this this dome here that you see here is is bigger I I enlarged my brain just to
make it look normal like this is bigger than what my actual head shape this is
bigger than what my actual head shape was and it's kind of embarrassing through me
what does that mean
doctored head size no it doesn't have a screen I don't like um I actually don't
like I don't think sorry I'm trying to decide if I should keep the the side
bangs I feel like they look a little bit it's a little bit hard for me to draw
them I always have problems trying my own side bangs so I might not keep them
but I feel like they're too much of a staple I don't know it's gonna be rough
it's gonna be rough I'm not sure my side bangs like gold on top of my hair and
on my hair my eyes oh we're really going in with this what 50 Baku Deku
tiktok's does to a motherfucker what do you mean what do you mean by that what
do you mean by that huh nothing it does nothing to a motherfucker you saying it
makes them emo or you're saying it makes them stupid and that's when my head is
so small that's when my fucking head is so small yeah I also wanted to round out
my eyebrows more I really really really really like round eyebrows so I'm
gonna round out my eyebrows I've always really liked round eyebrows I think they
really cute I already look so strange I feel like I'm literally just
recreating my own model yet for some reason something's wrong side bangs are
cute they are cute but I'm not good at I don't know for some reason a lot of us I
feel like everyone in Bieler has such huge bangs we all have like humongous
bangs have you guys noticed that or maybe except for Azura like I feel like
Strani has huge bangs um let me pull up the actual model too so I don't have to
keep maybe I can look look at my own reference just referencing my own art
from my own hair Strani has huge bangs mercy has huge bangs I have humongous
bangs um I see has huge bangs too it's not the size that counts it's the motion
of the ocean all right and then I want to do I want to do this the little
braids oh yeah I see it yeah we all have huge bangs does she be have bangs
I'm trying to remember what she be say looks like it takes a long time to cross
the ocean in a row boat what who does your hair because I can my monitor just
died who does your hair because I can just get the same hair cut for $20
rude big bangs big forehead yeah that too like it kind of gives me a really big
which I guess you know is it really accurate though to have a big forehead
because apparently my my actual head is like really really small underneath it
right something like like to have the bumps I love floofy bangs like old
anime yeah I guess that's true it does kind of I'm not really um I didn't watch
a lot of old anime so I'm not really attached to like the old anime style you
know I didn't watch a lot of old anime cuz I wasn't I only got into anime when
I was in like seventh grade I think so most of the anime I watched was not
battled I feel like I need to make this more angle
I mean half bald no just give me some time to give myself here and right yes
did I completely answer that I don't use a display tablet because I don't like
having the display I like to look at oh she bees here hi she be hi thank you
for coming and and and bringing bringing your hair I'm here how is your
stream did you do I can't remember did you play the crab game a crabs adventure
a crab something I think that's what it was oh god this is already looking bad
someone said I look like Wendy from Wendy's like the like the um maybe I
shouldn't make it them outwards like the fast food restaurant is that so wrong
is that so bad to look like Wendy's I think Wendy's cute another crabs treasure
yeah yeah yeah the mascot yeah the mascot from Wendy's you kind of do I'm I
don't think I do I mean I'm about to make myself look more like it but I don't
think I currently do are you gonna add freckles yes yes yes of course I'm
keeping my freckles and like I said before do not take this stream as like
an example of what the actual model will look like it's gonna look way cuter than
anything you see here okay I promise or at least the art itself will look cuter
maybe you won't like the design we'll see we'll see Wendy's approves round
eyebrows yes I love round eyebrows and you know what I'm gonna make them big
here yep big and round I love big round eyebrows
you okay you're coughing a lot no I'm still sick
hey Amy I'm finally getting a job congratulations oh my goodness I'm so
proud of you being jobless kind of sucks I can understand the struggle how did
they do this how did they make them look so cute because like when I had a job
like cuz technically I I didn't need to have a job but my mom really wanted me
to have one so you know I kind of had to be at her mercy and get a job and when I
did have a job she would be like don't you just love having money and and having
you know being able to buy what you want don't you just love it in my head I'm
like no because like yeah sure I guess I can buy what I want and I'm talking about
like a regular job like a like a I worked customer service and I was like
no because sure I could buy what I want if I could fucking leave my house at
any point other than to go to work because that's what I did I didn't leave
my house other than to go to work or to go to school like what am I supposed to
buy the things I want I can't leave my house otherwise I'm too fucking depressed
I don't have the energy to it's sucked it's sucked but anyways I wish you
luck at your job hopefully you're not like me and you can actually do stuff
other than have a job like outside of your job right relatable right like I
don't understand how people have like a full-time job and also like have hobbies
and go outside of their house and have friends I can't do that oh shit oh shit
nay way too real right take me back I hope you get your appliances and survive
today's economy all we need is hope I'll survive don't worry about me worried
about you yeah the top of my head looks a little bit sad
how we doing fellow wage cucks oh yeah something I wanted to incorporate these
um these little buttons I wanted to maybe I don't know I want to have them as
hair clips somehow like I don't know could I hmm would that look good or would
that look weird sort of looks cute it gets worse when you're full-time in a
job and full-time students still are trying to have a social life is that
even possible can you even do that incorporate the AR what's a AR oh here
got work tomorrow rise up wait no yeah yeah yeah I was gonna say isn't tomorrow
weekend no I'm gonna keep the pins for sure here let me actually bring up the
actual model itself that's where you can see where I traced it fuck why did I
save that
oh there's my naked body I forgot to put my clothes back on shit
close don't look close your eyes don't look there we go oh fuck I don't have
things there there there there all right there's my actual body don't look close
your eyes you were supposed to see that stop oh shit I don't have my sleeves on
either rip what no that wasn't that was nothing that was nothing just you
didn't see anything okay just don't say anything and then you too won't just
don't say anything in the comments don't say anything anywhere and then you too
won't delete it okay don't you want the bot to stay up for the poor vaude watchers
you know I saw it all stay no you can't even get off to that there was
nothing there there was no nips there was no nips lips there were there was no
there was no Gucci slips my eyes were full of tears what Neil doesn't know
doesn't hurt him exactly you keep that a secret okay you keep it a secret my head
still looks flat as fuck oh no wonder they made my the top of my head so point
it's because otherwise I look really flat at the top there that's a little
better that's for later right no no no no don't don't look at that later no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no all right um come on sketch you can't see my layers either
it's okay all right let's now I think it's a little bit hot to wear a collar instead of
a choker I just have a dent right up here that's my dent it's my headphone
dent I'm just such a gamer I wear headphones so often that I have a
headphone dent up there yeah that's the Tyler one dent my headphones just you
know they made their they made their place they claimed their place on my
head cuz I just wear them so often okay um I feel like I also should make the
hair wider too sorry I'm really picky this might be a really um stressful
stream to watch
me like wider
him so you do play league not a stinky league game or like you I think I made
it too wide now that's cute right I feel like maybe I kind of something inside of
me is telling me to flip these hair pieces so that they're facing outwards
like that you're the opposite of stressful really really I feel like I'm
very stressed especially when we play games together and I'm like what do I
do especially if it's like a horror game if it's a horror game and I'm like what
do I do tell me what to do please please please tell me what to do what do I do
next please please please please and I'm like freaking out I can imagine that's
like really really stressful to any viewer that's just trying to like watch
it and enjoy the game but instead I'm like screaming at you like I love that
about you okay good oh I do have some teal up I keep accidentally muting my
mic the rule of cool slash cute is why Mercy has a giant pair of scissors in
her skull also because of killer cool kill wait did you cool slash cute wait
what did you say something else I didn't I don't get it that's normal for me
being a person with three siblings oh good wait you have other siblings other
than me let me try your tea it's not good it's yucky I only like sweet teas
right wait I wanted a color I didn't really look up any colors to have I don't
know kind the rule of cool is allowing something silly because it's it looks
cool oh okay if it looks cool slash cute use it oh okay yeah that's a new level
of cheating having other siblings you thought you were the only one yes yes I'm
supposed to be the only one you have how dare you have other sisters other than
me okay I actually don't know what kind of color let me look up um let me look up
on Pinterest some collars and you can tell me if you like them or not okay
color like choker color
hmm
what if it's an older sister it doesn't matter there's only me only me a food
related color I'm not quite sure how I would do that
hmm
I like this one do you like this one how about that one hmm that's yay nay
hmm yes it means the best little sister in the world and she's the only girl I
needed in my life and I love her and what you like it you like it a bit simple
well the other the rest of the design is gonna be I feel like I'm gonna have a
lot it's gonna be a lot do you want to keep the Trinity not I don't know what
what is the truth
maybe I should keep the Trinity not not me not even knowing what's on my own
okay okay okay you know what no we'll keep the knot you're right what's behind
me she's right behind me isn't she she's staring at me from behind isn't she
I think what I'll do is I'll just make it like an actual little like a tiny
little pendant instead
like that except like more even and good in the actual design like I said don't
take this don't take this is what the model is actually gonna look like
there's something like that she's right behind me yeah we'll keep the knot in
don't worry we'll keep the knot maybe make it a little bigger the try not and
the pentagram was a placeholder now it's too lazy to come up with an original
design for an emblem at the time is the middle of summer don't judge me that's
okay skin walker why do you have a Satanism taboo on your pelvis region
watch the lore seems like someone didn't do their reps anyways is that cute I
don't know I might change that I'm not sure if I like it I'm not sure if I like
it well I'll probably change some change some stuff on my own
what is this oh that's the screenshot I'll probably change some stuff on my
own when I'm alone and don't have you here with me so I can okay what oh yeah
your shirt your shirt your shirt okay there so your shirt I want it to be off
the shoulder now okay I talked to starting about this because it was
something I really really really wanted to include but I'm not sure if we can do
it what I wanted to do is I wanted to have it so off the shoulder that you
could see a little bit of that's not it's just a little bit if you don't know
my um I have some I have some you know some of these and I wanted to be so off
the shoulder that you could see like a little a little tiny bit from from the
top of it like peeking through the top of the shirt but I know it might be
risking it I know I know it's it's it might be too much I know it would be so
sorry it would be lethal I know I won't I won't do it I won't do it
surrounding said you know she trust she trust my my um I guess my my my um
what do what do we call it my well she put her trust in me to do what I want
but uh yeah my judgment my judgment but I don't want to um I don't want to get
kicked off of YouTube I don't want that to happen so I'm not gonna do it but I
do want it to be really oversized like really oversized because I think that's
cute I like I like wearing oversized shirts and plus it's your shirt so
probably oversized anyways
bad mistake I'm so sorry if the coughing annoys you maybe I shouldn't
scream I feel like I scream a lot during my streams and folks a little ghostie
huh right and I also wanted to have it I also wanted to have the shirt be a
little bit ripped got I'm making myself literally into a fucking cutting board
right now maybe like just a little bit ripped no
you're fine okay is that the bottom of the shirt just long enough to cover that
is the bottom of the shirt just long enough to cover that cover what my
nipple tape no it's much longer if it's art if our if it's oversized just means
you stole one of ours this is your shirt silly stop asking stupid questions it
literally is your shirt how do you do that I've had size since 2015 and I've
never seen that before are you stupid are you stupid it's right here ruler oh
shit you don't see that well right above right on the left of filter there's a
ruler option and you wait no sorry I'm stupid that's not the right one sorry
sorry sorry sorry it's here let me move myself it's right here this one and you
can't see the options because I have a window capture on side but it's this
button and then this gives you all of the rulers cement symmetrical rulers yeah
and art lessons with any she's behind you she's back is she is she coming is
she getting closer how close is she right now to me be honest not my fault I'm
stupid but at least you still love me I do it's okay I'm stupid too so it's
okay right right right yeah I wanted to have like rips in it because you know
you're like dead and stuff so like I should be all ripped up because you're
dead you might be able to feel her breath on your neck the shirt's gonna be
ripped so high that all it says is don't piss me off you know I'm what what I
wanted to do was I wanted to have it ripped literally so it was like don't
piss me off just I'm close something like that but I think that looks bad so it
might just be don't piss me off we'll see we'll see and then rate the skirt I
don't know I'm conflicted between skirt and shorts but I think I like skirt
more are we undead no you're just dead you're just dead sorry sorry big bro
you're just dead I know I'm close would have been so peak I know but it would
have to be really like annoying like okay wait okay I have to be really
annoying we cut and I don't want to do that and also like normally I don't like
low-waisted stuff but I feel like I really I gotta show this I gotta show
this this is this is peak I can't I can't make a design without showing that
so we're gonna have to make it low-waisted unfortunately and then I'm
also gonna have the I'm also gonna have the the same are we ghost-possessing
the pumpkin doll yeah sure gotta be at least a little visible yeah yeah unzipped
jeans to show more I'm not I'm not some street whore unzipped jeans who do you
think I am walking around with my pants unzipped I wouldn't do that I'm not
son son filthy yeah you're tiny and cute just like me we're matching at least
which one is the real in me what do you mean I'm the real in me short set our
high-waisted but have a really loose unzipped zipper showing the tattoo
through the hole no no I I want my my shorts to be zipped unfortunately what
we'll have to keep them zipped but we'll keep it low-waisted I don't know if I'll
be able to recreate this skirt good enough or maybe I'll just have it flare
out like that like that
that cute I think that's cute
at least you're wearing some at all yeah I have Emmys one of Emmys doesn't have a
head and the only one is only head wait what do you what low cuts are hot I know
they are but I'd never like personally in my own wardrobe I don't like to wear
them cuz I'm self-conscious so I'm not gonna be walking around with my tummy
out but in this case I'm gonna be walking around with my tummy out
oops there
like that I think that's cute I think I don't know alright pockets pockets some
some pockets understandable it is understandable I'm exposing my whole
in musty to the world my entire in musty all right great I also wanted a belly
button piercing where's my belly button I didn't draw in my belly button okay that
doesn't look on that anatomically correct all women's pockets are useless
okay is that how belly button piercings work I don't think that's correct
that's a good change reflex for the skate for that for the frills I like to
draw frills I like to draw a lot of frills frills are like one of my favorite
things to draw other than hair I like to draw a lot of hair too so but I don't
think it's a good change reflex at all I'm just trying to I'm just trying to get
the drawing get the design down so that way I can like actually make it good
when I'm alone you know I kind of want to bring the shirt down a little more
just a little more
as someone who has tried but absolutely cannot draw at all me this way to see
shut your mouth don't put yourself down like that everyone can draw even you
just some people have to you know practice more than others which sucks
but that's just how it is for everything unfortunately some people just kind of
pick up stuff faster than others but you know everyone can do it you shut your
whore mouth I like doing hands okay yeah shut your
whore milk to hands get out of here with your stupid hands no one likes to do
hands that's not even AI can do
belly button hold small fluid inside belly what small fluid am I just stupid
today I found it really hard to draw your hair buns yeah that's something I
noticed like it's a little bit confusing from some artists maybe so that's why I
wanted to simplify it in this design it's just some cute rates
get out of here with your dirty mind none of my Christian Minecraft server
and I want to color this too okay yeah let me so let me just go look at women's
belly button piercings real quick so I can see what it's supposed to look like
my mom actually has a belly button piercing crazy in me lower so it's like
the top part of the belly button in order to draw hands you have to go live in
a cave and meditate for a cosmic revelation that's true that's how it
feels like oh yeah and someone said they want me to have a septum piercing when I
asked for design ideas alright sorry our mom has a belly button piercing isn't
that crazy yeah someone said they want me to draw a septum piercing but I feel
like this is not correct belly button piercing way and then maybe like a
little upside down cross I'm not sure if I'll keep it I'm not sure I love my
immobile sister thank you I love you too something like that
I know thoughts prayers you hate it I kind of hate it I'm not sure I'm not sure
thoughts and prayers it's cute okay okay and then here I'll draw the split tongue
too look small hmm I think it's a good size I think making it bigger would be
too big left sleeve needs to go down a bit oh you're right you're right you're
right if something is oversized like this it should be like not oversized if
something's off the shoulder like this it should be like off the shoulder right
more maybe I'll make this one up more
something like this
well that looks kind of strange come on are you gay why are you acting so gay
here mom and dad missed giving you some of your allowance thank you for the
420 that was really loud I'm sorry and also I have to make it mono I don't think
it was mono desktop audio mono there I'm so sorry if that was really loud yeah
that's on my left okay I made it mono now such a cute little shirt thief your
shirts not the only stuff I've stolen from you I'll never tell though you'll
never know unless you actually find it in my room which in that case if you do
it was the rats it wasn't me playing the rats they steal everything as you saw in
my stream they steal everything can't do anything around those bitches cuz they
just be stealing everything
klepto losses yeah it is my it's not I mean it's not my excuse it's not my
excuse it's just the truth that's just what happens it's not excuse
um wait wait wait the tongue the tongue I want to draw the tongue all right how am
I gonna I feel like I don't want it to look like a snake like that look to
sneak like I guess no matter what it's gonna look like it just looks it just
looks like my mouth he means as klepto as her rats no no no no it's it's
literally just the rats it looks like buck teeth you're right okay here I'll
just draw the tongue here as a reference for myself in the future when I
actually draw them all which I'm hoping to do soon I'd really I really want to
do it soon and I will share my updates for you let me look at pictures of
split tongues right now split tongue I heard that if you actually split your
tongue it's like not a good idea oh it gets like really split yeah oh my god
the tongue I see you I see oh you can see inside some of them
why are you acting so gay the one thing you have for sure stolen is all our
hearts oh thank you for the tip you're right I did steal your heart I'll admit
to that I'll admit to that but you still mind too so it's okay it's a fair
okay wow these pictures are so disgusting um yeah okay okay I'll um I
guess it goes pretty deep like that and then I'll put a little heart at the top
little heart piercing flight tongues you have to completely relearn to talk and
eat basically anything mouth related but if you have good muscle control you
can wiggle them independently that sounds like an awful trade-off oops I
wouldn't do this in real life but you know in um
there's my sweet tongue in anime whatever who cares it's anime
why teeth versus why shape tongue why teeth yeah it's a bad idea I will be
doing it IRL just just just in this drawing um I keep forgetting all right
I want to have like um mesh sleeves we're emo right so like let's let's make
some mesh sleeves and then just mash them up and have them go like all the
way up I have to say this but ton looks like a bit much we'll see I know um like
you know not everything might not everything here will look good together
right now but I hope that when I draw myself it will look better and if there's
anything you guys don't like you can like you can comment it on um I'll post
updates and you can comment it and be like I don't like XYZ I don't like one
two three and if it gets a lot of updates I'll remove one two three XYZ okay I
want you to like the I want you to like the the design
you're so talented shut up shut your whole mouth I am not but you do like XYZ one
two three that's good good I appreciate that thank you also my um my graduation
like ceremony thing is coming up soon and my mom was like okay I was I'm gonna
be honest I wasn't gonna tell my mom I didn't want to go I really really didn't
want to go and so I wasn't gonna tell my mom I mean sorry our mom I was I wasn't
gonna tell our mom about the about me graduating because I didn't want her to
come to the ceremony because I don't want to go to the ceremony I hate like I
hate I just hate big events like that you know school school graduating from
school geez I hate big events like that and they make me uncomfortable I don't
I don't I don't they give me anxiety so I didn't want to tell my mom because if I
told her she was gonna be like oh well you're going you have no choice you're
fucking going but she texted me and she's like hey when do graduation and
I was like soon and she's like well are we going and I was like it's okay it's
okay it's okay I don't want to go I don't want to go but she was like yeah
okay haha very funny we're going we're going go go go get the tickets right
now we're fucking going so unfortunately I have to go even though I don't want to
I don't even have like the stupid um what's it called the the outfit it's
especially bad if you have no friends like why even go to say goodbye yeah
that too I didn't make any friends at school so it's not like I'm going there
to like you know see my friends graduate and be like wow I'm so proud of my
friends it's like no I'm just I'm just going cuz my mom my mama is making me
yeah I know I'm sick I can't go mom she doesn't care she doesn't care um right
feet or socks okay I want fishnets on the socks too there there thank you thank
you for making me feel better give her the I have COVID excuse oh she's gonna
be like oh yeah you have COVID you have COVID okay give show me the test show me
the the the positive test 8 out of 10 we'll distract mom for you that's not
something she'll get distracted from okay I'm trying to think should I just
like okay I want to have different different like socks again so maybe
like one can be up here and one can be down here maybe stir up fishnets what's
that I'm not gonna live through my graduation no she wouldn't unfortunately
isn't the skirt too short what how is it too short go go short or go home if you
can't handle the heat stay out of the kitchen you mean too short that doesn't
exist here have you stream have you seen strontis outfit there's no such thing
is too short here maybe I can just have one like warmer shorter no if I go too
short then it's it's already a really tiny mini skirt my ass is already
fucking hanging out of this there's yeah exactly there's no gust of winds on
the internet to worry about um this is my idea board okay so I'm really
conflicted on what kind of socks and what kind of shoes should I have one like
warmers that's stupid looking what design on the pants you haven't thought
about that change it to a v-strake I'm not trying to get kicked off of you too
unless you fart again that's actually such a cute little um that's a that's a
cute little visual for me just tooting and and my little skirt just flies up a
little bit okay I'm going to I'm gonna steal this shoe I'm gonna steal this
shoe I'm not sure what I'm gonna do with it I haven't decided that yet have a
sticker instead of pencil diabolical
is that right
really bad
this is why I don't do art streams because I need to focus I'm so bad at
focusing on why aren't my feet fitting into the shoe
it still looks really big whatever it's okay it's okay is that our shoe too yes
stir-fish notes or socks but open on okay I'll look up what's there let me
look it up myself
open on the heel is that what I mean is that what you mean but I'm not showing
my feet though compression shoes I'm getting old your little sister has to
start wearing compression socks um yeah I think I'll if they're leg warmers they
would be like on top of the shoes so like like like like this
I'm like awfully drawn but like you know fold it on top of the shoes
something like that
some big dot stompers might be nice true but I don't want to I don't know I don't
I'll kind of attached to your shoes I don't really want to get rid of them you
know I'm already getting rid of the sweater
so I feel kind of like oh maybe I could have like a I don't want to bring this
all the way up maybe I could have like a like a band-aid kind of like what's
going on here take my Tim's instead do we only own one pair well it's the
fucking ones you died in so yes they mean they mean something to me okay they
have meaning to them and then I'll just quickly trace these shoes
they look like sketchers like light up stompy sketchers it's our other pair
shoes would be disproportional since you already have a short-sleeved
and grip t-shirt what's a Zetai real real key
Zetai real what's that
what does that mean what did you do to our dead party after we die oh my god
nothing I buried it I buried it don't worry don't worry I promise I buried it
your sweater on the other hand I can't say the same thing I can't say I did
nothing to that one bro I was so surprised once Johnny told me the back
story behind the fucking sweater and shit I was like nah nah you just pulled
that out of your ass right now there's no way that actually was planned cuz what
the fuck I'm not telling you what it is cuz it's like what like what made you
think of that where where did this come from
rigor mortis is great for long-lasting that's so fucking dark oh my god no no
no if your erection lasts more than four hours please please seek medical
assistance that's what that mean we think of
terribly terribly traced shoes but yeah look why does it look oh it's cuz my feet
are still inside of my shoes let me let me erase my feet
there we go that looks kind of stupid doesn't it
Johnny's mind is scary yeah don't tell us what you did to everybody I won't tell
you do the shoes light up that would be so cute oh my god like having um having
like a stomping animation and have the shoes light up that'd be really cute
maybe I should do that I think it looks off I kind of agree
but I'm not sure oh maybe I just drew the shoe badly I forgot I left out like
the details maybe if I add more details it'll look better
blink-do what's blink-do blink-do I'll think about lighting up the
sketchers because I think that's a really cute idea is that look better no I
think that still looks bad the leg warmers don't go far enough down hmm maybe
you're right I'll try to make them go far further down like like that
does that look better thank you for helping me by the way I absolutely
appreciate any um any back seating when it comes to when I'm confused in art
I think that looks a little better
make them light up really that looks great oh sorry I didn't show the whole
thing way better okay okay okay okay and then I'm just gonna um copy and paste it
to the other one
I love loose socks me too
there we go
oh it looks so cute new laurel dropped bro died from a tragic wheelie you you
were wearing airpods and you didn't hear me when I was yelling at you that you're
wheeling into traffic no and then I kind of like the band-aid uh I mean I know
this isn't a band-aid it's probably a sock but like I kind of have a mercy
I don't want to I don't want to get too close to her design
um maybe I'll just like maybe I'll have them even and then just put them like uh
what's it called more mesh up here
we got hit by truck you get you got you sick hide
maybe have a belt on the thigh
um a belt do you mean like like oops like this
like one of those like uh
fishnets on the upper thigh
okay
but make it one of those colorful kids band-aids with cartoons on it I could I could I'll try
to make them colorful here make make band aids more colorful because I think that's a good idea
you followed us into the isekai relosis or did you rip us out of the east I did not follow you
I'm sorry I'm trying I'm trying my best to follow you it's hard okay like like like fishnets up here
like that thoughts
I'll have to I have to go I'll watch the vlog okay bye bye thank you for coming
your necklace and it's pendant pendant thing include them somewhere
well I have a necklace and the pendant here
you like this you like it you like it okay okay I'll keep that
oh my god they're different they're different lengths fucking symmetric tool
and then I also want to like put the color put down on this string too
like belts would look great too okay okay maybe I'll add one
um I already have something on this like so I'm gonna add it on this like should I do like this
thing or should I do like a heart or something like tattoo oh my god it's like I went to jail
or something a tattoo
could have tied it around your wrist
I do want to have some sort of like magical looking design incorporated too
I do want to make that try a heart I think I might add like some crystals to the bandaid you know
this is an awful heart what the fuck
there
oh a skull a skull is a good idea too
oh this heart is too
it's a little bit too far out okay there
and then have the dots because it's a
because it's a belt
I feel like I look so basic give one of those mom tattoos but it says
bro instead no
and a heart on the other
okay um I need like a simple skull reference
I think having two is too much but I think I'll just keep the skull
I think on both legs is too much
you know what I mean I really like I really like this
oh no why isn't it copying copy image oh these stupid fucking websites
okay well I'll just try it myself
yeah keep the asymmetrical yeah I feel like both sides is too much but I think I'm going to change
this to a skull like uh
this is going to be so stupid looking like that that's kind of cute
right here let me make it a little bigger here we go a little skull
a temporal tattoo what's a temporal tattoo like temporary is that what you mean
perfect
there
you could do eye bags like dark circles I want to but I really uh I feel bad because I really
want to stay away from any other any other of the girls is um like design elements and that's
icy's thing you know I really want to stay away from anything else that the girls um the other girls
have you know a pin pal skull what's a pin pal skull a pumpkin shaped skull you mean
a crushed energy drink we're gonna we're gonna keep that in my shirt okay let me write the um
the text for this um
here
don't piss
don't piss just a pumpkin what about your needles what needles I'm not wearing needles do you mean my um
my nails
do you mean the nails is that what you mean
I'm pissed now you on Friday shut up shut up shut up shut up don't tease me about that yet
don't piss me off
um I think I'm only going to be able to have don't piss me off
I thought those were sewing needles
no these are nails like nails see like nails hammer nails kind of nails
yeah they're not sewing needles
oh you mean on my necklace um
um
I think they're vials I think
in my hair oh up though up there these yeah like up there the the red pins um
those are those are those are just pins
are you going to finish that
okay um so I think the don't is fine we make it bigger don't
piss me off
there
I'm not sure if they're crystals I'm not gonna lie they look like vials though
don't piss me off I guess I can keep on close to as well
oops what this is all of my layers are not they're not organized uh okay I can have
I'm close to as well are those leaves what are these their leaves okay
I'm close to
put it the put the I'm close in there
I I'm putting I'm close to I'm putting the whole thing
I'm close to
there and then all of it needs to be even smaller
and then the leaves
they're awful awful terrible leaves oh my god
I'm close to and then leveling up
don't pee on me
if you if you angle it a bit I'm close make sense
you know maybe I guess since it is technically you know
um
does that work are you sure
like that like if I really rip it up
don't piss me off I feel like it's too it's too um angled at that point you know
like it's too angled
you like it you want I'm close don't piss me off I'm close is that what you want
I know it's the same angle as the neckline but I don't know if it looks good
that's what you want
skew it to match the folding I can't free transform like that on
I need to go on cliff studio paint for that but I'll make it look good on the original
don't listen to us it's really funny but this is what I want okay I'll listen to you
I'll listen to you if this is if this is what you want I'll let you have it
um
I think we can color it now right
I think we can color it
let me just erase my body um in the parts where they're not supposed to be
so
it's cute and funny add the two but only the top of it so it looks like it's actually ripped
I'll just
I'll just write it myself there I'm close the skin outline what do you mean the skin outline
I haven't added the earrings yet but I'm not sure if I want earrings even
I'm really on the fence oh yeah fingernail I will have the fingernails painted yeah
because my ears are going to be covered most of the time anyways I'm closet I'm closet
you want bottom lipstick I feel like
I don't know bottom lipstick is I don't think I want any sort of makeup I think it's too much
a cheek tattoo like a little pumpkin
if I'm gonna put any sort of cheek tattoo it's gonna be this
I'm a murder
do you want that is that what you want killer this is the skin of a killer Bella
that's what you want
too crazy okay 69 no I yeah I agree like makeup is is a little eye dark dark eye corners makeup is
a little bit too much it's you got it we got to keep the the natural appearance you know
like that
we can have like maybe a little bit a little bit of like black under eye shadow just a little bit
tiny little bit you raised the moon tattoo oh shit you're right shit damn it why am I stupid
like this uh okay let me try to find it again
shit
I'm gonna have to remake it I know makeup doesn't serve the little sister aesthetic
my headphones are falling off
you mean has a big forehead place some more x and o on there
shut up it's not even that it's not even that big shut up it's not even that big it's very very
small and very cute like the rest of me okay there's no there's no giant forehead that you speak of
okay um let me see if I can just like steal this one tattoo here
I can like I said before I'm not tracing anything from the original design um or from the original
art when I actually draw the model art this is simply for design purposes only okay I promise
I promise okay take tattoo on your tummy then since we can't plan no don't touch my tummy
that's that's one of my roles don't touch my tummy okay okay now I'm gonna color it right
I think that's everything
bottom left oh shut shut up stop playing tic-tac-toe I'm not drawing a tic-tac-toe on my forehead
making me dirty and sticky like she doesn't wash her big brush
I feel like it's a
it's a black shirt though it's kind of hard to make it look dirty and stinky isn't it
oh shit like how do you
how do you why isn't there how do you make a black shirt look dirty
let me play with your piercing sure just don't pull it off please
or if you do make sure you apologize for it and then like my belly button clean of all the blood
stains stink lines
with brown colors
why are you guys so disgusting why do you want that
why do you want me to be stinky
white spots
adds flavors are you keeping the x people's yes yes I will I will keep those
you
dried blood I guess I could make some dried blood because I am stinky
well now I'm gonna make your fucking shirt stinky too I guess
okay I'll add some some some stinky stains I can't believe you're making me do this
why
here that that's
shouldn't I make it bigger maybe right here at the color
does that look like blood should I make it more red
am I allowed to have blood on youtube
we win chat this is a topic I know well that was the point we came here to be email I really
really wanted to play like email music but it's like it's um you know it's copyrighted should
I just sing it for you I don't know I don't know lyrics enough to sing it yeah it's just
ketchup it's just ketchup don't worry it's nothing else just ketchup
is there any other aspects you think would be really attractive
in this design anything else I should add you mean
they allow gameplay of doom oh really yeah it's just spaghetti sauce oh sure you're
right glasses ah fucking hell glasses
I hate I hate drawing glasses okay what what kind of glasses do you like do you like
like the wide the the like the big rectangle ones or do you like the thin rectangle ones
shut up about a monocle I'm not doing a monocle you're like round glasses
owl rimmed what's owl rimmed let me look that up
owl rimmed that looks kind of stupid aren't well they're like rounded rectangles big round ones
hmm I kind of actually maybe owl rimmed isn't so bad hold on
like something like this you like that
nerd no I'm not doing two monocles square frames they're cute
I think these are cute too I'm not getting super man glasses
maybe like these ones
you know what maybe it'll look cute actually
if her buck teeth no will it look cute oh wait that's kind of cute maybe they're a little too big though
oh it's kind of cute
pension emergency I don't know what that is can we go smaller no
okay let me let me trace over those real quick
um
I didn't actually expect to like any of these glasses this one's kind of cute
let's do this let's also do this
um
there super cute make them bigger okay let me finish actually drawing them and then I'll make them bigger
and then they have a little dot in the middle
oh I can't fucking see there we go
the glasses with the strap that prevent them do you want me to be a hag I feel like that's
very old person needle we have hags in the company it's not me I feel like that would make me look older
you know what I mean
an eyepatch to hide her demon eye to hide my sharring gun
I love my little sister I love you too
black dot left ones why why would I do that two eyepatches how am I supposed to see
you're just drawing me at this point
there
I feel like these glasses are really big though maybe if I dried in my maybe once I dried in
my own style it'll look better
you don't need to see only listen to our voice that's kind of cute why is that kind of cute
very cute
big is cute makes you look smaller okay okay okay that um let me actually continue the art
not the art but the
the coloring and maybe make this a little darker too
but then it's harder to see the blood
looks like you're wearing your brother's glasses when they don't fit you really
okay well if you like that
and then my skin
and
just gonna
and I uh I don't think the selection tool will work because my sketch is too messy
well maybe uh not really
are you shitting me
the size selection thing is so annoying
does this work oh I forgot to paint my nails too
good enough for me
everything Amy wears originally belonged to us yeah yeah this cute little mini skirt was yours
what are you doing what are you doing cross dressing in in in your room alone with this
little mini skirt and the thong too
are you secretly some little fem boy is that what you mean
I hope the prescription is is the same I don't know what's your prescription
I think I don't think everyone here's even wears glasses though
I don't know
I want don't worry I won't I won't
like you might
I wouldn't mind I wouldn't mind but I'm still gonna tease you about it if you do do that
because I think it's funny
okay after I'm done with the skin I'll I'll redraw the
the black nail polish
negative 2.5 left negative 2.75 oh that's nothing
onion stronger onion stronger prescription than that that's nothing
our girlfriend our girlfriend where these what do you mean our girlfriend
what do you mean by that what what huh our this ain't communism there's no hour here
you
the people's girlfriend
isn't normal to know your own prescription because I have no clue what mine is
no you don't have to know it it's not that big of a deal as long as your um
um you know as long as your eye doctor knows that then it's okay
can't spell in me without my yeah go on
hive minding I'm gonna change my thong to black because this looks a little bit
I don't know this reminds me of like I don't know this looks like a cowboy thong
it's just it's giving cowboy thong and um I am not a cowboy so I'm good
and here here it's giving like assless chaps you know
tanned leather thong yeah that's what it reminds me of
so I was just thinking like that sounds like it would hurt
and also I'm gonna make my hair a little bit more
a little bit more we're gonna do a bleach and tone here just a little just a little bleach and
tone just a little just just tone it a little bit
I still want it to be bright blonde but I don't want it to be like as bright because we're emo now
you can cowgirl if you want don't some of the people in here have mercies oh she mark
is that what the broken heart is what do you do I'm gonna go tell on you to mercy what do you
mean you can cowgirl it she's not gonna be very happy hearing that
she threatened us I threatened you what are you doing telling me to cowgirl it huh
you're gonna get us both in trouble
should I tell her is this not honest they want to get beat up please wrap them out
she's not alive so they're getting rowdy in the cage yeah apparently
they're getting a little thirsty for their little sister
it's okay I promise I won't tell her don't worry I'm just teasing you
castration I won't tell her but instead I'll make a deal with you give me your balls and
you'll have my silence how about that give me your balls and I'll take I'll take I'll be silent
I'll shut my mouth I won't tell her a thing
I need it for a spell
CBT Tuesday
also I kind of wanted to
I kind of liked these sleeves I don't know maybe I'll have some red on the stripes on the socks
I wanted to incorporate like the red more I don't want to only be black and white
you know
and maybe on the
on the bandaid too
have my sack ma'am thank you
I'll steal them in your sleep you're gonna wake up and you're gonna you're gonna feel some emptiness down there
but that's okay because you don't need them anyways
I'll keep the same eye color maybe make it a little less bright
I'm personally I personally feel like this this the brightness wouldn't really go well with this
design because it's so like you know emo so we gotta mute the tones a little bit here
I'm gonna put the X
so
there there's a terrible X I did what I could very thoughtful I know I am very thoughtful
I'll do it when you can't feel it so that way you don't have to scream in pain
Elden Ring playthrough would you want to watch watch me play Elden Ring
oh my god I'm actually really liking this design now that I look at it it's really cute
what is color theory at this point anyways I don't know
like if you want something to pop you can surround it by muted colors but um
we're emo we don't want anything to to pop out if you play I'll watch have you played a souls
game before no people keep recommending them to me for some reason even though I've made it pretty
clear like I'm not really a gamer so anything you recommend to me I'm gonna have a lot of
trouble playing but if you're willing to watch me struggle that's okay
as long as you're there to tell me what to do
also what are your opinions on adding a different hair color like adding some streets
would you want that I feel like it'll add to the emo-ness are you okay with that
I'm not sure a lot I'm sure a lot of people watch you can't sit through souls like
it is easily a tricky game I'm tired of every vtuber playing souls stop
should I beat the one exception and not play souls then
do they all really play souls games well there's probably a reason it's probably
because they're popular a rat tail break ew what the fuck no I'm talking like the different hair
color you know red streak pink could be nice maybe purple to match my eyes
I'll I'll think about it after I add um
after I add the rest of the colors
can I
purple would be nice add purple
Esteban in your pocket I was debating on adding some rats in here
I just feel like
I don't know it's a lot of work
it's a lot of extra work for me to draw and also a lot of extra work for the raker
and I'm kind of lazy you know
would you want a rat I probably wouldn't be able to include all of them
and also it'd be really it'd be really extra depressing if they fucking die you know
I like the orange black purple and red side by side purple streaks
you want Esteban
I don't need to worry about the cost but I also just need to worry about like how much
like how much I can I can draw you know the cost isn't as big of a deal it's more how much I can
I can make myself draw if that makes sense
I uh because I want it to be something I can do like
you know without too much stress in about it oops I forgot that I'm
that I'm using the reflect tool
do Dennis he's the most lore accurate
Dennis is a girl don't misgender my rat I could do Dennis
an unnamed rat no if I add a rat it needs to be named it needs to be one of my name
or apex wait you want me to play apex if she played valorant I'd go crazy
you'd go crazy with like rage watching me fail
maybe save it for a possible future upgrade on the model
that's a good idea
all right what color oh yeah I wanted to I wanted to have red and black socks
red and black scraped socks
I feel like I feel like the shirt isn't dark enough maybe I'm just going crazy
yeah it's okay for now
I'm a little bit cuckoo cuckoo puffs cuckoo puffs
FPS might be a bitch might be a bitch much I've never played um I think I played valorant
I think I played valorant once I don't really play FPS but when I was a kid I used to be
obsessed with this one FPS game it was an iPhone game and it was called battle bears are there any
previous battle bear players in here I don't think it was a very popular game but it was like a
little iPhone game and um it was a little shooter and I really loved but I really loved it I was
really obsessed with winning that game
was this synopsis it's literally just a shooter but instead of like like an FPS
but you know all of the characters are just bears like teddy bears and stuff
it seems like some of you know did you guys play battle bears
I'll break do I want to make this
nope hated the chainsaw motherfucker bro the chainsaw guy could like kill you in one hit
I liked him I like to play him but I hated when other people would play him that was my grape
I did when I was young battle bear stream I don't think it exists anymore
and if it does exist no one plays it
maybe I should do purple instead of red
but I need something to tie in the red pins
or should I make the pins black
I never heard of it right red would be better bright red
I don't know what are your thoughts on making the pins black
I don't know
what about gray
maybe a lighter gray
I kind of like gray
could be a darker red I think you're right I think a darker red would look better
I also feel like I need to make them bigger and move them
if you want to go red the skirt needs to be different yeah maybe you're right
maybe you're right because I feel like red and blue don't really look great together
I think that looks okay gray looks good there's no pink anywhere
well did I say that I would add pink anywhere
silver
silver what
change skirt color you don't know is something wrong does something look off
pink thong maybe that's a good idea actually
I need to name like my layers more
maybe maybe a bright pink thong it would look kind of corny though
it would look a little tacky
I don't know do you like that
and maybe I can make the pins pink too
like that I kind of like that I vote for black
yeah it does stand out more pink and blue look good together not but not but not blue and
but not red and pink ah fuck me pink and blue look good together but not red and blue I feel like
here I can I'll make a poll for the thong color
I'll make a poll for my my thong cover okay not color color thong color um start a poll
these are the important questions okay what color thong pink black okay start poll
okay which which color do you want let me know
I see it's like pink is winning okay pink one oh or maybe not oh no it's going down now
can we add red to the thong no because the thong because like this is this this is a gene
this is a gene skirt and I feel like red and blue don't look good close together so I don't
want to make the thong red both pink face with black rim um
yeah I guess that's basically what's happening here
okay pink is winning I'll end the poll
the pink would make it pop more I agree I agree I agree
yeah choose correctly heretics
and it does match my eyes you're right okay um then I think I might make your
I might make your shoes like white and black or should I make them pink too
what happens if you shirt with the thong well I guess it's just gonna fall down out of my skirt
no I'm not doing neon green
I think I'll try doing pink and white for the shoes
no
what are shoes really be pink I guess not I guess not well I dyed them pink okay
I recolored them for you
fine I'll see what red how red looks with the shoes
and if I don't like them I think I'll have to change them
yeah I just used a sharpie to color them black I mean yeah or pink I just used a sharpie to
color them that's all and then this is white
is this yeah okay
why wouldn't they be pink if you're also wearing our thong you're right you did say you wanted
to have a magical girl sub theme yeah if you can think of like
ways to make it more magical not magical but like um
like
like like I do magic basically add some magic elements but not magical girl
because that makes it sound like an actual magical girl which I'm not aiming for
you're so sweet what oh good night good night have a have a good more witchy yeah more witchy
if you have any way to make it more witchy okay yeah the red doesn't the red is the red
isn't looking right to me I think Amy being a magical girl villain character is worth its own
concept yeah that's true yeah a cult a cult like that yeah the red doesn't match she right okay let me just
I just uh I just bleached
where's pink I just bleached your shoes it's okay you don't mind do you
actually I'm not sure if I like pink either
black and red with pink strings would look good you're right
you're right it would
not completely black but
like that and then wait here
and then make those strings pink
yeah I'm never giving them back to you anyway so I can do whatever I want with them
I could noot in them if I wanted to and then make you walk around in them
awfully drawn actually I like that I like that I like that I think that looks cute
really just gonna noot in our shoes like that hell yeah I am
let me turn where it's pink and thrive it it's okay you can wear pink around me if you want
why in them and not on them so oh not on me oh why in them and not on me
it'll be on you if you walk around in them
I kneel it looks great okay okay um let me pay my nails real quick before I forget
just real quick we keep the black nails
okay
now imagining you talking to us from a portal and showing off all the shit you did to this
do you like how I customized your shoes big brother they're so cute now
they're so cute and they match my aesthetic okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna see how pink streaks looks in the hair maybe just like oops
um maybe just like a little a few of them um maybe brighter um maybe darker
um
um a tips maybe
maybe like the tips of the hair like that do you like that
that looks cute you like that
yeah are you gay why are you acting so gay you've really grown on me a lot lately I
need to run before I can't leave oh thank you you've grown on me too but don't run you already
can't leave super cute okay okay okay I'll keep the pink tips should I even go even further and go
like add some hair
like here too
do you like that I don't know get that guy get him bring him back to me
I command you minions bring that guy back to me
I'm pro diet tips
it looks like you're blushing you like it okay okay
I don't know I keep wanting to add more pink now
like like like even up here or like some
some some strands of pink
I feel like I'm making the strands look really bad that's my own fault
I don't think I like the strands yeah it might be too much
I don't think I like the side pieces pink either though I think I'll just leave it at that yeah
a hair clip that's pink I wanted to incorporate these hair clips maybe instead of bozo make them
these hair clips what do you think about that but that's too much pink in one area
yeah I'll try not to overdo the pink
I like the black ribbons I like them too that's a problem
okay um let's color the band-aids
real quick maybe I can do like um
like a bright blue band-aid here six out of ten that one was that one was crispy
that one was nice
I don't think blue looks good
does that look good do you like blue pink band-aid
I think pink would be a little bit too close to my skin color
do you like pink band-aid more
you like the band-aid I have now should I just make it like I guess the band-aid I have now
is pretty close to my skin color too
regular band-aid the same one as you currently have
try purple okay I'll try purple
oh that's might be too might be too purple
something like that do you like purple
okay
oh regular okay okay regular we'll keep the regular color then
okay not completely okay their regular band-aid color
purple looks like you stuck a big grape league chew to your face what's a grape league chew
a grape big league chew what the fuck is that okay um
are you gay why are you acting so gay
new design looking cute thanks for the good company and showing off your amazing art skills
aw thank you I'm happy you like it I'm so happy you like it maybe the maybe the band-aid down here
could be pink
big league chew why are you acting so gay
you know what I really have come to like you a lot so I'm going to stick around and keep
watching my adorable little sister thanks to me I love you lots oh thank you for the the tip I love
you a lot too oh what the hell I can't take two at a time it's too much okay
candy bracelets oh that's kind of a fun idea we can do some sort of candy bracelets
hold on let me see if a pink um
let me see if a pink band-aid will look good here
do you like pink I feel like this might be too much pink now
no
choose the limit it is the limit that's why I want two boyfriends
I like the pink you like the pink okay looks fine okay okay
um prick I forgot someone said something else and I forgot what what they said
oh yeah candy bracelets okay let me look up some reference for what I um what that would look like
okay so they're just like a bunch of different colored um beads right
is that it don't piss me off I'm close it it might be a little too much
oh something I also wanted to do was to have um
I want to have some rips here
I want to have some rips in the in the why can't I draw hello oh
does that look bad I kind of like the rip to look you could do a candy bracelet made out of
bone dice for the occult feel
you look like an emo wannabe middle schooler and I'm into it
I really like the gradient hair that's good
yeah rips are a good touch I like rips I'll probably like I'll probably add more rips um
um once I make the
once I make the actual design but there have some rips
but we've pivoted back into little sister territory that's good a wallet chain
I could add the book
on the other side do you think I should add the book I could change how the book looks I could
make it an emo book I can make it look come on how do I super I don't know if I have those
available yet I'm not sure yes at the book I was I was gonna make it look like my actual um
um like my actual like witchcraft book that I use hold on let me find the amazon mustang
I have to go back in my orders and find it um oh this is this is not the right amazon
I can make it look like my actual book and it's emo yeah it's emo it's very fitting for this
uh orders body can
I had a long time ago hold on
if I get it a long time ago hello
is this only from this year
page one of five show me all of the pages what
ah damn it I don't want to oh I found it I found it I found it it's um
here let me let me copy the image here it's this this is what it looks like and I think it's
really fitting oh shit it's not yep I think it's really fitting don't you I'm ready to judge you
this is not cute I think it's cute and I think it's fitting
the book title don't piss me off I'm close no the book the book will stay as the lovers
here I'll I'll do a terrible 3d I'll do a terrible 3d um rendition of it
it looks dope I know it does and you were you were doubting me
like that I think is that too big perfect right
oh
yes it does fit well I just have to figure out a good way to strap it to myself
like okay this is gonna be a really bad like drawing of it but I'm trying
I'm trying
well I'm not trying hard enough but you know I will try when the time comes we're just trying to get
the design now um okay so this is the backing so it shouldn't have any color just the book bind
and then inside it should be like the colors here maybe a little darker
maybe bigger a little overly detailed yeah I'll probably end up I'll probably end up simplifying it
um
just because it is um
it is very detailed you're right and also I'll make a better version of it
I'll add a better version of it I promise nail it to the left but this thing is on the left
I'm just flipping it to my other side
like that no it's from the top
like that hammer it with hammer it in with the nail no I don't like pain that much
maybe if you do it okay there
a really shitty version
do you want hammer or nails in the design still I don't think I want the hammer I don't think the
hammer would fit it could perhaps be tucked under the skull belt it looks a little less busy
under the skull belt
I'm confused
yeah it's some contrast
maybe more pins
are you saying you want nails in the design still is that what you mean
a ghost of us floating around you
are you asking me to draw like the pin pals um
like the the the pin pals um oh sorry my mind is going blank
like the fuck what's the word yes
the skull belt on the thigh could be part of a book holster uh that's a really big book though
to be put on my thigh right yeah mascot you want a math you want the mascot too but like a ghost
is that what you mean you summoned us as a spoopy ghost that floats around
I don't think I'm gonna include like actual lower accurate me chan here
oh here I thought of an idea actually
um
um never mind never mind I was gonna say I could put the nails in my head instead of the pins but
I uh Dr. Nova E from before me I already has that and I don't want to I don't want to copy that um
on the book cover you and the mascot but I like this design I'm not gonna that's gonna make it look
silly I think um if you need something smaller than a book there's always a turret deck yeah but
the book has meaning you know to the lore so I feel like I should um keep it as a book but just
like change change it a little bit why am I so bad at like
am I doing this right
whatever tummy mouth with a split tongue what's a tiny what's a tummy mouth
I think adding more stuff might clamor it up clamor it up you mean like make it too busy
are we the ghost on each hand or the mascot you're both
I could I could add a little ghost mascot but I don't think I'm gonna do that now just because
I'm getting really hot and sweaty so I think this will be here I'll make the tongue bigger
I think this will be our design for now and I'm I might add a little more um
um
where's the tongue I might add like a few more smaller details myself but
this is like the main point and you made it with me so that makes it special
there and let me delete this list up here
and maybe also color in the tongue what color is my tongue
there
there's my beautiful split tongue you're not ready for it
should I add stitches to it or is that too much is that not sexy
can you tell me if that's not sexy
do you like that what are your thoughts on that
I'm not making my tongue green yes the stitches no two stitches hot looks weird
you don't know too much no stitches out I was asking for a split tongue me I am
like plushie tongue not for me okay
weird it's weird I think it's kind of hot I have no thoughts on that imagine if it falls apart
no okay it seems like most people are saying no okay I won't add stitches I'll just keep it split
there
here's our final our final emi redesign I think it's hot good stitches are good okay
I'll do another pull I'll do another pull for the stitches start a pull stitches on tongue or no
no yes okay hold on stitches on tongue question mark yes no okay there
cut my life into pieces this is my last resort I'll bring it back just to show you oops no
this is what the stitches would look like kind of
okay it seems like the majority want no stitches stitches are too much okay what happened to my
oh there we go
okay 62% want no stitches so I'll end it there and we won't have stitches on the tongue
I'm converting to stitches you can't change in you can't change your mind now
I'm imagining what kissing stitches would feel like probably not good but I'm not gonna lie I find
it hot so I won't do it though if you don't want it I won't do it there maybe make the
maybe make it a little more obvious that this is a
make it a little more obvious that this is um
um
up here sing
there
yippie we did it
they have cosmetic stitches that you can put inside you and do designs inside of me what
okay well this is final mostly final design here I'll make it big screen
ta-da thank you for for designing it with me that's now this is emo I really like it I think
it's super super cute Amy is so talented I'll post it on Twitter after this so that way um oops
oh ria's here oh shit hi we were just about to end oh shit okay well hello welcome we made
her worse not really not really joatt invasion what jote jote invasion what is a jote are you a jote
huh does it have something to do with what your stream is is this some inside joke
that I'm too normy to understand goat misspelled oh joke throughout throughout joke
okay um here I'll post it on Twitter right now
just so I don't forget because I tend to forget stuff like that
pictures
our our emo redesign tongue tongue emoji
let me know your thoughts
okay post that
me when no viewers streams after Amy what do you mean wait is no one else streaming right now
oh my god this is a rare case
what
what no one else is streaming no other viewers girls are streaming okay well that's okay um
if you have um another another um streamer if you have another vtuber you want me to raid I can
do it I can't do a marathon stream right now it's a revealer bros um yeah if you have another
streamer that's currently streaming I don't know um no just end you cute little sis where
from you may plus oh okay well then we read maro I don't want to like I don't want to I don't want
to leave without you know rating someone we go raid maro
there we go she is streaming okay we go read her
right
she's not ending soon right
we only want you thanks for this stream I know I don't want to I don't want to leave either but
I I can't I can't stay so um thank you for designing helping me design myself I really really
want to want to get it done soon because I'm really excited to to to use it I think it's
super cute and the fact that you helped me make it makes it like 10 times more special
so yeah um I'll see you the Thursday I think we're I think Thursday we're doing the group
collab on Thursday so I'll see you Thursday you're ringing it too no I'm sending it to a
rigger to get it rigged because I don't like rigging um but yeah bye bye thank you for the
head pass I'll see you Thursday for the group collab and then um we'll have our endurance stream
on Friday 12 around 12 addt okay bye love you
uh